I asked you I posed to you why managers
have no problem inventing a new notation
right they're like oh you know what's
the sum of something let's just use
Greek letters oh I need to have another
symbol for the Sun would use the Greek
that I know let's just write a letter S
and make it really long okay as for some
doesn't stand for her anyway um house of
Superman general Oh God mathematician
have no trouble making up new notation
and yet they've recycled this notation
what does it mean usually what do you
take it to me when you see this two
vertical lines you usually take that to
mean absolute value right so you take
all the absolute value of negative 3 is
3 and 2 you all it means is just give me
the positive number it's all it means
what did I define it as here I defined
it as distance I just find it as
distance do you see let's go back to the
number line over here if I said to you
the absolute value of negative 3 it
doesn't just mean lop off the negative
side it means what's the distance how
far is negative 3 from the origin and
the answer is it's three units ok so now
you can say well what's the distance
from the origin of anything and it go
off in all these kinds of weird
directions so make a little something
conversion
and let's do a really quick one okay
so the first thing we're going to do is
now that we know we can represent these
numbers graphically I want us to draw it
doesn't have to be beautiful I'm just
the drawer where this number is okay so
you need your ID and diagram like so you
can see I haven't drawn the whole thing
because I know which quadrant I'm going
to begin I've got a puzzle number here
poison number here so I'm going to go
off one unit on the real axis should
have learned that bit lazy how far do I
go up the imaginary axis root 3 now you
might know not know if I drew three off
the top of your head is it's about 1.7
okay now again did you notice straight I
just did that you've got two different
forms I could say root 3 insert for all
I could say in decimal form but Destin
was a lot more useful to me because if
there's one and two I know where one
point seven years whereas likely where
is that so I'm going to put root 3 where
it should belong is root 3 and this is
the imaginary axis so if this is 1 and
this is root 3 where's 1 plus root 3 I
it's going to be over here right maybe
you want to put in some lines to show
the rectangle that sort of makes it
rectangular form so now what do I need
out of this if I want to convert this is
already rectangular form how am I going
to put it into polar form i need two
pieces I mean this guy what's it called
again the modulus and then I need the
other piece which is the argument so
that's the angle measured up from the
real axis there is that how am I going
to do this any suggestions okay so i can
either go for the argument first or for
the modulus if I've got both pieces it
doesn't matter which one go for if you
want to go for the argument then I can
say hello I have gone out this side here
which is adjacent to theta right that's
one and then I've got this side here
which is opposite theta which is root 3
2 opposite adjacent that means 10 so i
would say tan theta equals opposite on
the jason you happy with that yeah does
anyone know what that angle is off the
top of you you should be able to see it
in fact if you've drawn it even
reasonably it's 60 degrees but we know
better than 60 degrees 60 degrees is a
third of a straight angle like it's a
third of a straight angle so i'm going
to say the theater is pi that's a
straight
13 you happy that so I know my argument
how am I going to work out my modulus
just to Pythagoras right you've got your
two shorter sides so you can say that
the modules here are my Pythagoras is
going to be the square root of a look
it's 1 plus root 3 squared so that's one
plus three so that's the square root of
4 which of course is so how am I going
to write this game more art form in
polar form i'm going to say instead of
this i'm going to say z is equal to r
outside all cos theta plus i sine theta
now before i finish i want you to notice
you need a distance you need an angle
right the distance is unambiguous you're
like that's only two okay but there's
more than one angle that you can turn
around you can rotate through that will
get you to that point right pylon 3 is
one of them can someone give me another
angle that I could rotate through and
still be facing at z I could do this pie
on three and then I could just do
another 2 pi do you agree with that it
would still have me facing the same
direction because 2 pi is just a
revolution so 2 pi plus pi on three I
believe that would be seven five three
seven five point three
now interestingly these are the same
number it takes me to the same spot
right I face at the same position and I
go the same distance but as you can
imagine well which phone do you think we
prefer we prefer the top one right
because sleight learns to be redundant
life good for you if you like spinning
around but I prefer just go straight
there ok so what we do is to remember
what I told you about square roots is
that every nonzero number has how many
square roots to but one of them is more
important and we call it the principal
square root ok let's finish there's an
infinite number of angles and every
number of arguments that will take you
to this number but one of them is the
most important one the smallest one and
we call that whatever you think we call
that the principal argument make sense